uh thanks for having me on your show are
you kidding me no I
yeah see you're funny yeah it's my thing
so you were hanging out with reason and
is it true that she like just had cracks
and she rips me ribs tell me how I met
her at a party and she immediately
started making fun of the shoes I was
wearing and uh and she said to my wife
she was like so you just let her leave
the house wearing these shoes
and she just goes in we were at the on
the red carpet the other night and she
turned to me and she said
you have cat hair all over your
jacket and to be fair it was true
um but that's what I'm looking for uh in
a relationship whether it's my wife or
friends or anybody I love a good ribbing
okay so you're on the morning show yeah
I I actually have a professional
question oh yeah which is how are you
I'm very tiny natural and dry and good
and seen stealing and funny and
confident like how do you do it drew
first of all your kind second of all
when directors come up when I see a
director walking my way and I'm like oh
they're going to give me a note I
immediately stomp them and say before
you say anything I have no range but go
ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
you have these loyal audiences and yeah
I love it I absolutely love being in
front of a live audience and
um nothing makes me happier makes me so
happy so I hope you love your job
and I'm so attached to it
[Applause]
and I get to be the kind of parent I
want to be I get to have this life with
my kids you know and our little
ecosystem and our animals speaking of
you had cat hair on the carpet yeah
um on the red carpet yeah on every car
that I go on I on this carpet I have cat
hair you have your cat has an Instagram
yeah how did that come about
I mean what no
I started the Instagram account because
uh I just uh wanted to look at my cat
all the time and a woman from Iowa
started following
my account so I just started posting
pictures for her I don't think she was
even following me it was just my cat and
then I did a show with Kevin Nealon and
I showed him my cat
and then he was like oh that's tigg's
Instagram handle so he tagged me and now
I have more followers and I never I
don't want to be verified I don't care
about any of that after I got so many
people looking at it I just started
promoting my stuff and my cat barely
shows up now
listen I'm embarrassed to say well you
shouldn't be and actually in honor of
fluff I have something for you that I've
recently discovered
so thank you so much so this is this new
thing I discovered
um and I I do want to demonstrate how it
works do you mind okay no so okay so
what you want to do is oh my God I'm not
kidding I brought my cat peach in it and
then you fasten it in the back it's very
stable okay and what you do is you put
your cat in here and in fact here
[Applause]
here we used to add that okay so this
thing is not only for cat but it's also
for two other reasons I'm finding it's
to ensure that you never find a partner
yes absolutely
you find your exact perfect partner
it is like
um I have three cats so could I get two
more of these yes absolutely
ladies and Gentlemen The One and Only
tignataro
good morning
shine on Netflix which is out now
[Music]